it was a tense standoff at about 8 30
monday night police formed a line and
moved in on the protesters
about 100 people had gathered near the
pacific highway border crossing police
arrested 12 people for mischief and
intimidation bringing the total number
since sunday to 16. a few blocks away on
8th avenue some vehicles were towed
while others packed up their belongings
and drove away the arrests made last
night at the pacific highway crossing
were a part of an operational plan that
was in place prior to the enactment of
the emergency act
so all arrests made last night were
under existing authorities and not
related to any emergency
authorities for three days commercial
traffic had to be diverted but by
midnight
crossing good the first truck crossed
the border
by morning there was one lone protester
off to the side officers set up
barricades and a checkpoint before
allowing vehicles to go through drivers
were being questioned about their travel
plans so you can expect that there will
still be some delays if you are trying
to access that border crossing and that
is just to ensure that we are able to
monitor the situation to ensure that it
all remains accessible
protesters started gathering at the
pacific highway border crossing over the
weekend at one point some trucks jumped
to median and breached a police
barricade officers also formed a line
asking protesters to
leave nicely once police are expected to
remain on scene to ensure roads remain
open and traffic continues to move
across the border grace key global news